one of my first came to the house and
then he said the dumbest [ __ ]
question he goes well who's that oh
that's my brother you guys need brothers
for [ __ ] you just say to me
as I know did you just say something
brother
my whole [ __ ] life you [ __ ] but you
watch enemy yeah no that's just of a
little kid though so it just kind of
continued like my main one is little not
at though none of those so good I even
wonder like all the jutsus they had to
like I legitimately know like so many of
them I had this urge to just punch you
have useless talents well just say that
you know there's all the handsome show
them right now
go come to the middle I show them all
the [ __ ] that you go alright now we're
this way so people wouldn't know that
you guys are very geeky you know just
from the look of it people wouldn't know
but the great thing about that is is
that you guys are very comfortable in
your own skin we always tell people did
to do what you want [ __ ] with everybody
else things but any other people would
like this or very you know they're happy
about this should you kinda keep keep
they don't let talk about just condo
I'll actually understand why they would
delay is probably the place where it's
only the cool thing to do like I I mean
when we weren't in LA it wasn't cool and
we weren't cool when we did but not like
wouldn't you do it in LA people actually
think that's cool I remember I dressed
up as Neal one day oh my god that's
right what's up front man you were weird
you would do like some of the moves from
the movies yeah but like it's like it a
completely like normal life nothing is
greater we we can see ourselves get into
this world and our body gets into it
especially for me action wise so I did
like the sweeping leg move and in my
head everything else is like in the
world of the matrix finish it like how
oh that was cool and then I couldn't
feel like anyway at the real world and
if you've been walking by me at school
and going oh my god so that happened to
me a lot
so are you teaching him martial arts
like he didn't how come you know
marshals he doesn't so I've never done
martial arts before I started doing it I
started doing flips in high school and
he loved you
so we met these girls for me was the
first okay the first start was we met
this girls
Alicia and franking when I met them and
the really cute twins and they asked me
a question and you said yes you should
join it so both of us joined it yeah we
like so we could hang out with them and
oh I can you do backflip over my leg
when I sweep I was like totally like
great can you do it now I was like yeah
I'll get back to you it's been a while
since I've done it so oh so you did a
backflip for a [ __ ] girl too
- groans oh my god we're still friends
now
Alicia Frankie hi so hold it what will
you go with the purpose of you you're
just assisting no witnesses Aled
legitimate alleges why don't you
introduce the brother to the 12-week
many this is the finger a lot of people
know this but almost give me every
single [ __ ] Korean guy they don't
want to play a [ __ ] guitar and the
last girls and it wasn't because they
went to church and they were doing it
for the Lord
they wanna study Korean Christian [ __ ]
hey come on you know worship sounds
they'll be fine worship and chill like
some of the most gangster dudes would
roll through and they only specifically
because they knew they were cute girls
at the church and they you know I'm a
big woman even pregnant just come
through
dear God like you know say man like you
know [ __ ] [ __ ] know what kind of
[ __ ] prayer is this so Sarah you've
been with for about six years
have you guys ever got into a fight
where you were like - a little [ __ ]
about your wives
damn it means that we we don't really
argue too much more so that we are like
listen what you did if it's that wasn't
cool and it's just like why was a member
so we kind of talked about and the thing
is Peter tonight we have this anything
everybody already knows we're like super
close and we're we're more femme than
most people so we talked a lot of our
feelings out like whatever we have
problems we talked about and we had to
bring that into our group of friends -
like Manny doesn't like talking about
stuff now shut the [ __ ] up now yesterday
when you talked about my hair that was
really rude wrong with you open up a
boxes and no never never yelling damn
you
see I never thought that I would yell at
Muriel either but she's pushed me to
that point but once again I'm with the
Korean woman so she she angers me on
purpose comedian you ever see that one
coming that talks about like girls don't
ever say there's no reason to hit a girl
there's every reason to hit a girl you
just don't know he used to watch like
these specials right it would be like
like I don't know like CNN they don't
like do these [ __ ] [ __ ] why would
you ever even think about putting your
hand on it I can see I can see why you
would think it you know I would never do
it but don't but I could see you know
why because girls they like to push her
buttons so that's the thing like when a
guy says something it's always on
accident when we can only [ __ ] up so
we'll say something like hey I don't
like the way this sucks sheet you hurt
their feelings but like oh [ __ ] that was
an accident my fault I wasn't trying to
do it on plates but then like Mary will
come back with like that's funny you're
fat all that whoa [ __ ] like daggers
you know yeah you don't notice that it
like hurts until like after you she
wants are you like there's no gradient
like it's like this so here's a fourth
before example I said this in the video
before we go I'm like what's up jackass
she goes sup [ __ ] I'm like what hold on
a second you can jackass is cool you
can't call me a [ __ ] she goes then both
curse words I like no just one up the
[ __ ] I mean it's like I said hey weird I
hey small dick I really doesn't know how
to hit you to it
how did you know you're such a peaceful
women you know why it is cuz you didn't
[ __ ] get with a Korean women are
beautiful but man they're like fireballs
I'm so they're like fair to say I told
us to Ellen Kim Korean women love and as
hard as they hate someone this one
they're very affectionate they're super
affectionate they tell you that they
love you
they're super cuddly I always talk about
how combative like Muriel is but the
thing about is that's the type of women
are like so it's not it's not like I'm
saying like well if you want like a
little bit I say she's me because I
she's not me she's [ __ ] sweet as [ __ ]
I just I just have a very strong
personality so she has to learn how to
deal with me and it brings out this
other side of her so it's more so that
you need to find a girl who can handle
you I've been with women who are very
passive and you know that's kind of
annoying I can't stand like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] women like that are boring I wasn't
the rear I want something where I look
at a god like your Beatle she goes to
[ __ ] you titties I'm like
GATS to what I'm talking she's the woman
that I chose for a reason I'm not gonna
have Kay dance doc because that is
sexual this was where the first ones to
[ __ ] everything it's true no it was in
high school dancers were the ones that
were the most sexually active they were
the most talking about I had this and
that so quiet no when did you lose your
virginity oh your question no no